les entreprises stratégiques italiennes
relancent leur chaîne de production
après quasiment deux mois à l'arrêt
guissepe comté a autorisé la reprise des
activités industrielles voués à
l'exportation afin de rivaliser avec la
concurrence étrangère le géant de
l'automobile fiat chrysler a donc décidé
de remettre au travail ses employés sur
plusieurs de ces sites à mirafiori dont
la banlieue de turin
une centaine d'ouvriers ont repris le
chemin de l'usiné après un accord trouvé
entre syndicats et direction
nous avons eu une réunion avec
l'entreprise vendredi et nous avons mis
en place un accord-cadre conclu au
niveau national en l'adaptant au
contexte de cette usine aujourd'hui un
nombre limité de travail reprendra puits
de jour en jour leur nombre augmentera
en fonction des besoins de production du
modèle 500 et des besoins techniques et
organisationnelles de l'entreprise prise
de température distribution de masques
et de gants le retour au travail
s'effectue sous très haute surveillance
les autorités veulent à tout prix éviter
une deuxième vague de contamination et
impose donc des mesures sanitaires très
strictes
malgré ces précautions les travailleurs
sont entiers au moment de reprendre leur
poste
by jybo on m'a donné quelques masques et
une paire de gants ces précautions ne
sont pas suffisantes
juste la gare de gand vous allez aux
toilettes vous en revenez puis vous
devez aller manger comment est-ce qu'on
peut gérer ça il y a toujours un peu de
tension parmi les travailleurs
il ya des inquiétudes pas seulement à
propos de nouveau dans l'enceinte de
l'usiné mais aussi pour nos familles à
la maison
l'italie tente peu à peu de sortir du
confinement imposé à sa population
depuis le 9 mars dernier à milan la
régie des transports publics met en
place les règles de distanciation social
dans le métro et les bus avant la phase
2 celle du déconfinement prévue le 4 mai
prochain